Alberto Fernández ha insistido en los
logros de Lula como presidente y en las
necesidades comunes de los países Lula
ha hablado por su parte de retomar las
relaciones que nunca debieron acabar Qué
valor tiene esta muestra de apoyo común
y en qué punto están ahora las
relaciones entre ambos países tras el
gobierno de bolsonaro
pero muy buenos días Muchas gracias
nuevamente por la invitación Creo que
uno de los puntos centrales como Rodrigo
gobiernos decía es que Lula se encarga
de decirnos que Brasil está de vuelta
pero Brasil que está de vuelta en esta
relación con Argentina pero también con
toda latinoamérica Brasil vuelve
pensando en el intercambio comercial
pero más allá hablamos de temas
energéticos Hablamos de una moneda común
que parecería no ser una moneda común
sino más bien un sistema de pagos en
monedas locales pero también se habló de
democracia de mantener el estado de
derecho de cuidar los Derechos Humanos
Brasil vuelve buscando mayores
intercambios comerciales pero mucho más
se ha hablado también estos días de un
posible impulso en la integración
regional incluso de la vieja idea de
crear una moneda o como usted indica de
un sistema de pagos En qué punto nos
encontramos respecto a todas estas ideas
Sería posible una integración que dure
más allá del signo político de los
gobiernos
pero muy interesante la pregunta
es como vuelve pero
en la idea ya hubo declaraciones en el
día de hoy desde Brasil más vinculadas
como decíamos a un sistema de pagos en
monedas locales no tanto en la creación
de una moneda común o una moneda única
para el mercosur que eso parecería estar
muy lejos de los intereses actuales pero
también de las perspectivas a corto
plazo Considero que hay temas
fundamentales que resultan prioritarios
en este momento más allá de esta
intención de la moneda única que se
concretará en un primer paso como
decíamos con un sistema de pagos en
monedas locales Qué temas prioritarios
podemos encontrar sin duda retomar los
temas políticos como lo decía Lula Silva
creo que está muy claro en su discurso
eso pero también otros temas como puede
ser medio ambiente o los acuerdos con
terceros o incluso podemos redoblar La
Apuesta medio ambiente en los acuerdos
con países Esto sí va a dar un impulso a
la integración regional Además no es un
dato menor que Lula en su primer viaje
al exterior va Argentina y en segundo
lugar a Uruguay creo que esto es un
símbolo que los podremos encontrar no es
a Estados Unidos no es a China esa es
latinoamérica y dentro de latinoamérica
Elige a la región respecto a la celac
una de las principales polémicas es la
posible presencia de Nicolás maduro sin
embargo se canceló una posible reunión
entre el presidente venezolano y Lula da
Silva cuál cree usted que es la mejor
manera de tratar la situación de
Venezuela y de otros países como
Nicaragua por parte de los países de la
región
Bueno Este es un tema que fue
especialmente polémicos no no solo por
las respuestas sociales en Argentina un
país que se encuentra polarizado
políticamente sino también porque había
sido el argumento de bolsonaro para no
participar de este proceso de
concertación como es la celac tengamos
en cuenta que no es un proceso de
integración como el mercosur sino que es
un proceso de concertación política y
Qué era lo que decía bolsonaro Bueno muy
bien no vayamos a estos lugares donde
pueden estar presentes estados que él
consideraba que no eran democráticos
bueno justamente Esta es la polémica que
hemos visto en los últimos días en
Argentina no solo es el sentido el
entender que tenía bolsonaro sino
también en dentro de lo que serían los
demás partidos políticos en Argentina
también se hace sentir esa idea
si ustedes me preguntan qué es lo que
considero es importante el diálogo es
importante la negociación con todos y
esto no implica que no se estén
condenando las violaciones a los
derechos humanos o en algunos casos que
se pueda
cuestionarse existe o no una democracia
pero ese cuestionamiento será jurídico
pero la negociación será política
entonces me parece que es importante
estar en un mismo foro de qué nos sirve
tener a un estado afuera y simplemente
señalarlo con el dedo lo mejor es
dialogar y poder aportar a esos procesos
que pueden ser polémicos o criticables